on january 20th 2021 i posted a video
called
why microsoft refuses to launch windows
11.
for the first couple of months there was
a plethora of comments suggesting that
my video was useless
as i was apparently stating the obvious
microsoft had already announced that
windows 10 would be the last version of
windows
years ago so this was nothing new
over the last month though the video has
been flooded with new comments
this did not age well this aged
like fine milk this aged well this aged
well
this aged well this aged well
this aged well there's a few hundred
comments within just the last week and
yelling down the point that the video
didn't age well so let's just make it
official
the video aged like milk with that being
said though
microsoft did initially suggest that
windows 10 would be the last numerical
version
and just a couple of months ago people
were convinced that my video was just
stating the obvious
so what changed for microsoft and where
did my reasoning go wrong
in the last video i outlined four major
reasons for why microsoft refused to
launch windows 11.
so let's go through each of those
reasons and discuss the merits and flaws
with each argument
starting with resources developing a new
windows operating system
is not cheap by any means we don't
exactly know how much it costs microsoft
to develop a new windows
but some simple math would suggest that
runs them tens of billions
for instance let's say that microsoft
uses ten thousand engineers for five
years to develop windows 11 from start
to finish
glastro suggests that the average base
pay for a software engineer at microsoft
is between 83
000 and 178 000 the team working on the
latest operating system though will
likely be the best of the best
so we'll estimate on the higher end of
the spectrum and call it 150k per year
add an 30k cash bonus and a 50k stock
bonus
and we get a total of 230 000 per
engineer in terms of compensation
if we add in 70 000 to account for
office space laptops
phones airplane tickets hotels and other
operational expenses we get a total of
three hundred thousand dollars per
engineer
spreading that over ten thousand
engineers over five years
we get a total of fifteen billion
dollars to develop windows 11.
microsoft also has tons of expenses
other than just development
such as marketing providing support
forming new licensing deals
and the opportunity cost of using that
much manpower on windows development
clearly creating a new windows is
extremely expensive
and that's still true today however
something to also consider
is that microsoft is a significantly
larger company today
in the early 2010s when microsoft was
developing windows 8
and 10 and decided to end it with
windows 10 microsoft stock was hovering
between 25
and 30 dollars per share today microsoft
stock stands at 265 dollars per share
and microsoft just surpassed the market
cap up two trillion dollars
not to mention microsoft is now holding
135.8 billion dollars in cash
fun fact if bill gates never sold any of
his microsoft stock
he would nearly be a trillionaire today
with a net worth of 900 billion dollars
anyway something else to consider is
that microsoft was now profiting a
little over 10 billion
per year in 2015 so developing a new
windows would require that they invest
two years worth of their net income
today however microsoft is now profiting
nearly 60 billion dollars per year
so developing windows today would only
require about four months of their
income
meaning that microsoft can gamble with
new windows and they won't really be
hurt financially
moving on my second point in the last
video was that microsoft had no
financial incentive
to launch a new windows here's the thing
no one buys standalone windows licenses
anymore in the 1990s and early 2000s
the practice of buying a new license and
upgrading your os was decently common
but that's no longer the case you either
pirate the latest version online
or you wait till you buy a new computer
to get it bundled with the new computer
also 99 of the population is not going
to buy a new computer
just to get the latest os especially
when the changes are more incremental
than
ever before microsoft realized this
years ago that's why they basically made
windows 10 free for consumers
they were like we know you're not gonna
buy a license from us
so instead of downloading the os from a
sketchy website and potentially getting
a virus
just download it from our website
nowadays virtually all of the revenue
from windows comes from computer
manufacturers
and businesses slash goals who have to
license it from microsoft
and the revenue from these groups isn't
going to change just because microsoft
launches a new windows
global computer sales aren't really
going to change because of the new
windows
so microsoft would get the same revenue
from computer manufacturers
meanwhile businesses and schools are
going to cycle through computers at the
same rate as
always so there's no change there either
considering this not only would a new
windows cost microsoft a lot of money
but it wouldn't even increase their
overall revenue this
is actually still true but what we have
to consider
is that there are other benefits aside
from just financial benefits
specifically branding benefits windows 8
and 10
weren't received too well by the public
with windows 8
microsoft dropped the original start
menu and they added some weird
tell thing and that alone was enough to
ruin the entire os for many
when windows 10 was released a lot of
the older software stopped working
and microsoft started to track our
activities and internet habits more than
ever before
let's also not forget the constant
updates which are often more detrimental
than helpful
just a few weeks ago my ethernet driver
stopped working after windows 10 update
as you already know the launch of
windows 8 and 10 were not smooth by any
means
and they arguably hurt the reputation of
microsoft and windows
with windows 11 microsoft is looking to
change its perception with what is
hopefully a super smooth transition
so though microsoft still doesn't have a
financial incentive to launch windows 11
they do have a branding incentive next
up my third argument was that microsoft
had far larger opportunities to spend
their resources and efforts on
as opposed to just windows and a
microsoft office
microsoft basically stalled after the
dot com crashed in 2000
between 2000 and 2014 the company as
well as the stock just went sideways
while it's true that tech companies were
vastly overvalued in the late 1990s
like they are today the tech industry
itself was still rapidly growing
though companies like amazon and nvidia
were crushed by the dotcom crash
they recovered extremely quickly and
destroyed the dotcom highs by the end of
the decade
meanwhile we had a group of laggard tech
companies that included companies like
intel cisco and of course microsoft
intel and cisco haven't surpassed
their.com highs even today
after 21 years so it was clear which
companies were innovating and
pushing forward technology and which
companies were just stalling
unfortunately microsoft was one of the
stalling companies
and they couldn't just keep trying the
same thing over and over again as
that clearly didn't work they had
already missed out on the smartphone
market and the internet to up incoming
startups such as amazon
and google so it was time to ditch their
old ways
and search for new opportunities to grow
fortunately for microsoft their new ceo
satya nadella
had just the solution cloud computing
services
google and apple already had a pretty
good grasp on the consumer cloud market
with google drive and icloud which were
extremely competitive
on the business side though there was
still a lot of room to grow
and there was only one major competitor
which was amazon web services
who was extremely expensive microsoft
believed that trying to leverage
business cloud was far more valuable
than continuously developing windows
so they put windows development on the
back burner and went all in
on cloud according to microsoft's
website their cloud service
azure is five times cheaper than
amazon's aws
aws is still arguably the most dominant
player
as they boast the best reliability and
service however
azure was an extremely attractive option
for businesses who are looking for a
cheaper alternative
and this allowed microsoft to break out
of 14 years of stagnation
and grow exponentially over the last
seven years in the early days of azure
in 2014 and 2015
microsoft refused to focus on creating a
new windows but
now that azura has gotten a strong
footing within the cloud industry
microsoft is able to divert some of
their focus back onto windows
and bring us windows 11. and that brings
me on to my final point which was that
microsoft
is no longer a consumer business while
it's true that virtually all of the end
users of windows
and microsoft office are everyday people
basically all the revenue for microsoft
comes from business to business
transactions
computer manufacturers businesses and
schools are the ones buying windows
licenses
employers and schools are the ones
paying for microsoft office
subscriptions
and businesses and schools are the ones
buying azure cloud services
so microsoft is indeed more of a
commercial business rather than a
consumer business
today but then why are they refocusing
on the consumer side
of their business at first glance the
move may seem confusing
but if we look a bit deeper it's
actually super clear
the reason is apple over the last couple
of years
apple has been going through their own
transition to reduce their dependence on
the iphone
one of these efforts has been increasing
the market share of mac computers
last year they ditched intel chips in
favor of their own m1 chips
this move wasn't simply to produce a
reliance on intel though
this move was designed to help max match
the framework of ios
and attract mobile developers to mac one
of the primary
reasons for the success of the iphone is
its ui
but apple can't be solely credited with
the iphone ui
i mean how long do you spend scrolling
through your home screen and using stock
apps
the vast majority of your time is spent
using third-party apps
and the reason the apps work so well is
because of apple's developer friendly
architecture that is tailored to their
various devices
so the success of the iphone is actually
because of both apple
and third-party developers in fact the
app store transfers a large portion of
apple's profit
from the iphone as a result apple is
trying to expand its success to max as
well
with the m1 this shift already seems to
have made a noticeable difference
in q1 of 2020 apple's market share was
5.8 percent
in q1 of 2021 however their market share
was 8
now it's not like mac os is about to
overtake windows
but microsoft doesn't want to miss out
on the next big ecosystem
right now computers don't really have a
central app store where you can download
everything
you have to download programs one by one
from their websites
apple is looking to change this and
microsoft doesn't want to be left behind
and this perfectly explains your
unexpected decision to bring android
apps to windows 11.
they're even open to steam being part of
the windows 11 app store
microsoft is also letting developers
keep 100 of the revenue from their apps
unlike apple with the iphone app store
so even though microsoft is more of a
commercial business today
they don't want to lose customers to
apple or let google create a dominant
app store for windows
and that's why microsoft is trying to
reinvigorate user and developer interest
around windows
by launching windows 11. will you guys
be getting windows 11
at launch or even earlier let me know
down below
also drop a like if you're hoping that
windows 11 will be way better than
windows 8 and 10.
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to the more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari i'll see you
guys on the next one